we have an update now from the family of
officer shea
mccolonies last june mcloney's was shot
in the head after
a protest on the strip he was taken to a
special rehab facility in colorado
but is now back home right here in las
vegas reporter kate houston spoke to his
family about his recovery
today i spoke to shea's stepfather
patrick neville he says shea is back
home and now
able to talk and this is great news
after the shooting happened doctors were
not sure if he'd ever speak again
o'shea has been home for a few weeks
after staying at a medical facility in
denver which specializes
in spinal cord injuries his family says
he's still paralyzed and on a ventilator
now shea is going through a transitional
period to adjust to
in-home care his family says being back
in his hometown is a great morale boost
for him
and they're happy he's so close since
he's been home he's been able to see
friends and enjoy the fresh air after
months of rehab
in his hospital room in his house he can
just
go out his bedroom door and he's in his
backyard
his friends can come over and visit with
him he gets to see people we've taken to
the station so he can see his squad
members
um so i think that's really positive for
shay and just to be able to small things
that a lot of people
don't realize is just be able to go
outside
is really a big deal moving forward the
focus is to get shea
stronger and to see him progress even
further
neville says he'd like for shay to also
be around people who are dealing with
the same mobility restrictions
neville says the support from the las
vegas community and from around the
nation has been
outstanding his family is making sure he
sees
all of the calls texts and letters back
to you